[Music]
tina knowles lawson just dropped a
teaser for her new facebook watch series
talks with mama tina and she recruited a
mega star to record her theme song
you guessed it her daughter beyonce i'm
just so proud the 67 year old shared the
preview clip to instagram which includes
some of her a-list guests like kevin
hart so good
sierra zendaya i'm really excited kelly
rowland and tiffany haddish i want her
to be my mama just to name a few as for
the theme song it kicks off with tina's
four grandkids solange knoll's 17 year
old son jules and beyonce's kiddos
nine-year-old blue ivy and four-year-old
twins sir and roomie before queen bee
drops a line
[Music]
how cute is that
i love it and tina she was clearly
grateful for the special treatment
captioning the post quote thank you to
my baby beyonce and my beautiful
grandbabies for making this special
theme song for the show the proud mom of
two added that she's excited to have
quote honest heartfelt conversations and
to share her quote famous gumbo with the
stars and some of their moms and fans
won't have to wait long to tune in talks
with mama tina premieres on facebook
watch on wednesday december 22nd and
from the teaser clip it looks like we
can expect some good convos with chloe
and halle too it's just so amazing of
course the sisters are signed to
beyonce's record label beyonce is such a
gracious human being and it's easy to be
around her and talk to her because she's
so kind and humble she is amazing
and appeared in the grammy winners 2016
visual album lemonade
they even opened for bee on her
formation world tour that same year
that just means so much to us how she's
you know giving us all these incredible
opportunities to share our art so we're
incredibly grateful
and while tina might be kicking off a
new business venture for her it's all
about family in fact when eti spoke with
the new tv host back in may she opened
up about getting more time with her crew
during quarantine
the best thing of course was being with
my grandchildren almost every day and
and
i think it made us appreciate each other
seeing friends and seeing family you
realize what was important you know so i
think a lot of good came from it